so when it comes to some of the
challenges in rolling out um and
actually embracing a new approach that
really stresses how people can bring
their authentic self to work and it
required us to change for example our
our approach to talent acquisition or or
recruiting um as as one example it's not
okay to have
limited uh interview pools for example
we had to make sure that we demanded
more so often and i'm sure um
anyone who's hearing this it's like oh
we couldn't find enough of x y or z
candidates well then you've got to look
harder and so that means taking a second
look at where um and and how we actually
approach and describe our organization
so this emphasis has to be authentic it
has to be true and so when we put
together interview teams when we think
about development programs
sponsorship programs it's not just
mentorship but sponsorship programs
we're always thinking about and and
we're always including what will this
mean to diverse candidates what outcomes
will they want to have how do we
understand cultural differences and
actually embrace those as part of what
we do and that's how you make it part of
your dna so there were challenges in
overcoming no it's not you can't just go
to the usual suspects you've got to look
differently you've got to think
differently we've seen a a twofold
increase in different categories
in in some of our regions for example
we've actually doubled the number of of
women in technology which is a great
result that we're really excited about
we look to other organizations that we
can also model and learn from and so i i
do want to
thank google for recognizing us not only
for our our our diversity equity and our
belonging efforts but also for our new
technology uh approach uh lifework
technology that has allowed us to not
just collaborate but really advance
uh uh ukg and take a different approach
not just to how we support our customers
but also how we work and how we come and
present ourselves in the in the
marketplace so it's been a it's a it's a
huge honor for us um but one that we are
excited to earn and again and and
continue to advance our relationship and
our partnership with google so thank you
so much google for these awards